kindness is magical because
it doesn't just make the person that
receives that to kindness
have a lift right and have a better day
it also makes the person doing the kind
that feel better about themselves you
feel good you feel good when you do
something nice for a human being so
that's
what i think my team
talks about when they say that they feel
that
kind mate makes them better people that
we're constantly striving to be
ambassadors of kindness and everybody
makes mistakes but it's an aspiration
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to ford this week one of the
world's greatest entrepreneurs and that
is no exaggeration
you know him as the founder of kind
snacks daniel lubetsky
joins us daniel welcome thank you andrew
so great to be here with you
yeah so daniel people who follow me know
that i'm an avid fan and consumer of
kind snacks i've got a little bit of a
proof point right here in my hands the
uh cranberry almond variety but you and
i have been friends for years we met in
the white house in 2015 and the story i
tell
is that we're there for an hour or so
we're all kind of waiting for the
president
and then you say hey is anyone hungry
and we are all famished so people say
yes and then you open your jacket
pockets and they're replete with kind
bars of different flavors and so you
just start distributing them and i joke
that you're like the batman of snacks
and i still remember this in part
because they weren't even normal kind
bars they were like prototypes of
different flavors i have never seen
since then
you know andrew the other part that you
may or may not remember is that then we
went into the oval office when we were
named presidential ambassadors for
global entrepreneurship
president obama joked you know did you
not bring any canvas for me and i did
not have to respond i said well i do
have some if you'd like and he said go
ahead and i ran for my backpack and i
ran back and the white house
looped it in
they actually in their video showed me
running like
the most pathetic runner in the world
like
because a i don't know how to run but b
was like fast looped so it looked like
oh they sped you up
so silly but i literally brought um kind
verse to the present which of course
breaks all protocols because you're not
supposed to bring food to
the head of state but he asked for them
and uh apparently he mentioned that they
have them
in
what do you call it
marine one is that what it's called sure
marine one yeah and i didn't know what
marine one is if that was a
a submarine but it's apparently their
helicopter they have yeah
so people love kind snacks they see them
everywhere
but i want to retrace your steps a
little bit because everyone always wants
to know how an entrepreneur uh can get
their start so you grew up in mexico and
then in san antonio texas and i think
one of your earliest entrepreneurial
experiences was running a watch kiosk in
the local mall
in san antonio uh which is you're being
very you're being very generous when you
say in the local world that was once i
had made it big and i was in college but
when i was in high school
i immigrated from mexico when i was 16
and i couldn't
hold any job as an employee because i
didn't have a legal permit we were there
legally because my dad had a business so
he had the right to bring us as a family
but i didn't have a right to work so i
created my own business which is part of
what happens with a lot of immigrants
we're forced to
start businesses because not legally
allowed to be employed but i used to i
used to start in flea markets and drive
for two hours and sell all sorts of
gadgets and watches
in
the
most fascinating
uh environments in the outskirts of san
antonio like an hour away or so and then
i graduated to a network of student
sales called daleki brands or delegate
times
and then i had a couple kiosks and
shopping malls in uh across san antonio
texas and all college students manned
those and a lot of fun
crazy experiences well you must have
felt like you made it when you made it
to the mall
it was it was like the fancy
thing the cutting appeals there compared
to
survival of the fittest at the uh
at the flea market but the flea market
teaches you so many fascinating skills
too including how not to eat an entire
turkey leg
my brother would join me and you know it
was thanks to my dad that we got started
because he was in the watch business and
he gave us a hand and so you went to
college in san antonio trinity
university yeah and so you kept up with
that business for quite some time
through your college years uh you you
then went to school in the bay area i
felt like that must have been a real
shift for you by going from uh mexico
and san antonio uh to the bay area but
you didn't stay there that long i think
after that you came east uh it was a
huge shift
nobody's ever asked me this question but
it was really an incredible world shift
mexico to texas was
because mexico i came from a
very homogenous jewish school private
jewish school and in san antonio i went
to public high school at robert lee high
school back then that's what it was
called and he was uh he was quite high
experience i don't think we have time to
go over but it was fascinating but i
enjoyed it a lot and then
moving to i went to stamford law school
but being in the bay area it completely
opened my mind to ways of thinking and
being more much more respectful and
talent and in in many ways your question
andrew traces who i am because i
was in such many different environments
and it taught me to respect
the way of thinking in texas as well as
california and try to build bridges
between those and respect that people
might have differences and they're not
you know evil just because they have
differences of perspective
yeah i mean you you took that bridge
building
approach all the way back across the
world to the middle east uh you did a
fellowship and then spent
years uh trying to connect the israeli
and palestinian communities politically
and entrepreneurially which strikes me
as like a monumental challenge and uh it
seems like that actually led you to food
somehow is that right yeah but
what's interesting about your question
is how little i knew and
hence how lucky i was because had i
known how hard what i was undertaking
was going to turn out to be and maybe
would have not had the courage to do it
and a lot of times for any young
listeners of yours
that
innocence uh
actually is a blessing because maybe
you'll make more mistakes but you'll do
things that are meant to be done but
that others that know no better quote
unquote wouldn't do
and so i first started a company called
peace works bringing neighbors israelis
palestinians jordanians egyptian church
to trade with one another using business
as a force for bringing together and the
concept the mission was so important to
me that
i just kept with it for 10 years even
though it was it was definitely
a challenge and then you were alluding
to something called the one voice
movement that i built uh as one of the
builders with a lot of israeli and
palestinian partners but here was this
confused mexican jewish american going
into the gaza strip and tel aviv and
jerusalem and
staying up till 1am negotiating with
palestinians and israelis on how to
build this movement which became one of
the largest grassroots movements
in the middle east and certainly in the
palestinian and israeli cities where it
operates which to this date is a voice
from moderates to amplify their voices
from pieceworks and one voice came kind
and starts with us which are the core
things i do now yeah so kind gets
started uh 2003 2004 uh and it is born
of the fact that you're on the road all
the time and you're like what am i going
to eat that doesn't make me fat and out
of shape very quick
which by the way is something i can
totally relate to um so i'm going to
share for a moment uh on the
presidential trail you would eat crap
all the time and so i go to rest stops
uh and then uh the temptation is to grab
junk food um but i kept so you this is a
true story i would go in and i would
immediately be like do they have kind
bars in this rest stop and kind has been
one of the fastest growing
food companies in in the world over the
last number of years but i will say that
you know rest stops in iowa it was not
it was not
like
not carried very often so like i would
fight myself um you know trying to find
some some
no you didn't find kind bars in rest
stops in iowa i'm gonna work on that
right away so the company gets started
uh 18 years ago and now it's ubiquitous
now everyone sees it but you start it in
part because you think that there is a
real need for healthier food yeah i mean
like you were saying andrew i was uh
crisscrossing the united states uh as
well as setting benches for peace works
ventures all over the world
and skipping lunch or dinner while you
know going on my tracks to try to get
kind buys in different stores or
traveling or just
working in my desk and just
wanting a healthy snack and back in the
you know mid 90s even early 2000s snack
options were nothing remotely close to
what we have today there was just
nothing that led with nutrient rich
ingredients even today by the way we are
the number one healthy snack uh in the
united states and probably in the world
it's fascinating that the number of
foods
snack foods packaged foods that lead
with a nutrient-dense ingredient it's
very very small the vast majority of
packaged foods lead with an empty
calorie or like you know just a filler
or just like
sugar or refined flours that lack you
know nutri uh nutrient density and it's
part of the problem with obesity and
diabetes in america that we're you know
these things like sugar and refined
flours cost
10 to 20 x
less than a nutrient-dense ingredient
like whole grains whole
almonds tree nuts and stuff like that so
it's understandable that
large companies
oscillate to make products
that are
really
devoid of healthful uh ingredients but
then consequently we pay for it at the
hospital with we have one of the most
it's fascinating because the united
states you look at the data
we are extraordinarily strong on
fighting infectious diseases you know
with kobe being
maybe one of the daunting tasks for the
last several years but overall over the
last 50 years we've just done a great
job as a nation in fighting infectious
diseases but inflammatory diseases are
just growing and growing and growing
heart disease
uh diabetes and all sorts of ailments
that are connected to our lifestyle and
we just need to do better as a nation
you mean to say that
companies are somehow
cutting nutritional corners uh to make
an extra buck daniel i'm shocked shocked
i'm showing everyone listening to this
also
i mean it's unfortunate we all know that
like sure it's quite cheaper to produce
an unhealthy snack no it absolutely it
and it's not it's not like evil ceos are
sitting there and doing the things how
do we do it's just they're looking at
the numbers they're looking at like hey
how do we make money and kind is very
lucky that most people didn't go the
hard path right they they go through the
easy path and but it is hard for
companies because
using nutrient dense ingredients means
that the products cost more and you have
to charge a little bit more or
significantly more and some people can't
afford them and certainly brands might
not be able to command that price power
to charge what you need to charge for
products made with nutrient-dense
ingredients but it's also an
agricultural policy issue because we
subsidize
sugar and empty calorie type mono crops
and we don't do enough to support
farmers that are trying to just eat by
and survive
making
more diverse crops that are more helpful
so it's a big policy challenge
what are you sleeping on right now
seriously i want you to think about it
because i used to not give any time or
thought to my mattress and then i got a
helix mattress and i'm telling you this
it's freaking remarkable helix
mattresses some of the most comfortable
mattresses on the market and they're
fantastic so how it works is helix sleep
has a quiz that just takes about two
minutes to complete imagine your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you so why would
you buy a mattress made for someone else
get one made for you and with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
be the perfect way for you to sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that
there's lots of different mattresses and
models to choose from so i got one
that's like medium firmness because i
sleep on my side all the time it's
perfect for me cannot complain and my
brother who's just casually sleeping
over loves it as well this mattress is
freaking gold you don't take my word for
it it's been awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine all you have to do is go
to helixsleep.com
yang take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life for real they have a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk free so helix
right now is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and
two free pillows and they're lovely for
our listeners that's helix sleep.com
yang helixsleep.com
[Music]
for me and for your audience anybody
that's starting out and that are younger
and that are following so i know you're
following is amazing but it includes a
lot of young people
you never know until you look back how
fascinating all the connectivity in your
life is but
kind would not exist today where not for
peace works and specifically kind would
have not been so successful where not
for the mistakes that i made at this
works and so it's okay when you're
starting something to make mistakes you
and i and you've been friends through
many turns and what i love about you too
is that you make a mistake but you learn
from it and then you absorb and then you
become stronger and so one of the things
that i love about your presidential
campaign that it just not sufficiently
commented on is the math which was i'm
like why does he want to encourage math
jesus just you know reaffirming that
asian stereotype that asians like math
but no was much deeper than that it was
make americans think harder that's at
its essence what we need to do more of
in our country i go back thinking to
your make americans think harder thing
because
if we're more introspective
our failures are going to make us
stronger if we are more curious and more
comfortable listening to the other side
we're actually going to be stronger in
advancing our causes make americans
think harder is literally
what our nation needs the most of by the
way why have you not emphasized that
just as much why did you move on from it
because i really think it was genius who
came up with that did you come up with
that or did somebody else give it to you
uh so what happened was uh i was
doing an early presidential talk very
early like early 2018 here in new york
to uh some entrepreneur friends in new
york uh and then one of them said uh
andrew you know why you're gonna do well
is that the pendulum tends to swing in
opposites politically
uh and so right now we have donald trump
and then the opposite of donald trump is
an asian guy who likes math and i heard
that and i said like ah that's funny
there's some truth to it um and so i
started using it in
speeches and i remember that line a lot
but but that preceded m8h yeah so i used
that in some speeches and it got
applause no no no but i i'm curious if
you don't mind because it's fascinating
it's one of the smartest
models that have come up and we don't
sufficiently appreciate it
from an asian guy who likes math to
math who came up with that that was like
reverse engineering you realize that
math was sexy for you and then you came
up with m8h
yeah so someone online uh on a reddit
forum i believe
said like math is an acronym it stands
for make americans think harder we
should find that person because it's a
really i wonder where they got that but
it's really cool that you absorbed it
because
but had you thought before about how
essential that is in american society or
it was just a coincidence well it was
something of a counterpoint to make
america great again mega
and so one of the reasons why trump is
so effective is that
um that there were such strong
symbols and images and uh tribalism and
uh and thought well we should have a
positive version of that and you know it
happened to have four letters as well
so the blue math hat
we sold several million dollars worth of
them uh plus
um so it became this major campaign
symbol but i will say we did kind of
stumble onto it well i think you should
do more with
make america
think harder and your forward party
which is really cool
could uh integrate that because i really
think about it a lot a lot of what's
happening to our nation
is we're losing that
curiosity gene that self-reflection
skill set and muscle that made us the
most amazing nation on earth and that
hurts not just
civilization that hurts not just you
being a better parent that hurts you
being a better entrepreneur because how
are you going to have and drive
creativity if we are
scared to debate and to listen to one
another and to learn from one another
one thing that people always enjoy
daniel and i'm sure you've got them is
those entrepreneurial war stories where
you're like this is like a pivotal
moment in the the company's history uh
i'm sure you have that with kind i know
one thing that happened with kind is
that people started
seeing you and saying like ooh like
let's try and uh buy your company or
bring you in
um and that you started getting offers
for kind uh years and years ago where
people were and so some people would
look at you and say like hey you should
take that offer
i don't know
i don't know if um if there are
key moments in kind history that you
reflect on fondly well all the time i
mean and also us entrepreneurs and
people that are older than 50 start like
getting a little bit too enamored with
our nostalgic moments i love thinking
back and reminiscing and i i really
tried to be very self-reflective not
just about the great moments but even
more about the things that went wrong
because those that's where the lessons
are that's what you can learn but for me
what's fascinating is how kind started
it started the toughest year of my life
because i had just lost my father
and so my dad was like
my mom and my dad are
so important to me in my life my dad was
my role model and my hero 2003 was a
very very tough year i was
starting and launching the one voice
movement because it was one of the
toughest moments in the
violence between palestinians and
israelis there was just so much division
so much polarization sadly very
reminiscent of what i see happening in
america today which terrifies me and
it's for me the impetus for some of the
work i'm doing
but as someone that really cared about
resolving their israeli conflict since i
was a kid i was very very focused on
that and then my dad passed away and i
was in the midst of trying to
launch kind what became kind but back
then we didn't have a name for it we
named that kind partly in honor of my
father who in spite of surviving the
holocaust and being in a concentration
camp and being treated
as a sub-human you know not even
not even as an animal but as a
sub-living species he
he approached life with kindness towards
all and and i was very grateful for
everything and
we sat around the table my team and i
and almost didn't launch kind because i
had a business setback with a product
line that i was importing that had just
lost all of its distribution and so i
had put all of my earnings
into this line that we were importing
and then the manufacturer that we didn't
control the manufacturing back then had
changed the ingredients and added
artificial ingredients so we were forced
to tell the natural trade about it and
as a result we've lost basically all of
our business overnight so i was with
seven team members sitting down uh in
our little office and i said guys should
we throw in the tile remember i had
already been doing this for 10 years and
fortunately we decided to give it a shot
but it's fascinating that kind almost
never saw the light of day we almost
didn't launch
the genesis of kind was one of the
darkest years of my life and one of the
darkest moments and i literally was
almost hoping that my team members just
said like yeah let's just go do
something else and they would give me
permission to go find a job somewhere
but i also it wasn't just about my
future was my team member's future and
they encouraged me to um fight and i and
we you know then the rest is history
what was your personal life like at that
point had you met your now wife when you
were making this decision to launch what
no no 2003
when my dad passed away it was a very
tough time i had a i had broken up
recently with a girlfriend she was very
nice to me after that
but
but it was a very tough year it was
really really hard and no i didn't have
i hadn't met michelle i met michelle
three and a half years later well for
people who are going through tough times
uh you know i think this is a great
story and outlook that incredible things
can come out of dark periods and i've
seen that in other instances actually
uh one truth is that
the best businesses are started in
recessions uh so if we end up
in a recession and you're trying to
start something you should know uh you
know it it may turn out to be very very
successful how long did it take for kind
to hit its stride after you made the
decision to
uh to start it with the team kind took
off overnight i mean it just it was like
my first 10 years at peace works he was
two steps forward two steps back two
steps forward two steps back like it was
very very very tough i never broke
three million dollars or two and a half
million dollars in revenues at peace
roads
kind doubled every year every year for
10 years and you know the law of compute
you know oh yeah that adds up quickly i
can't stand up quickly so kind was
really really great in in that and
because of what i said earlier and all
the mistakes we made at peace roads were
weren't obsessive about strategy we were
not obsessed about quality control
like at kind we were obsessive about
really keeping the brand guard wells the
reason why kind took off is we were very
true to the brand we were very very okay
this is what the brand stands for and
we're not going to deviate and if our
brokers want us to launch another
product because this is doing our or we
could just i know unless if the quality
is right and the brand proposition is
met till today we're very obsessive
about trying to really uh keep the kind
promise the the mistake i made at kind
is
because of my 10 years at peace works
where i was just barely surviving i mean
i think just to make sure that your
audience understands
my salary
ten years after graduating from law
school
was twenty four thousand dollars a year
oh my gosh
and i recovered myself sometimes i
sometimes couldn't pay myself and i had
to skip and i barely made payroll for my
team sometimes
i wasn't like
suffering like other amazing american
citizens who are literally
not able to pay for the health care for
the children i had my parents backing so
i knew that if i really struggled i
could have called my dad and my mom and
they would be there for me but still i
wanted to do it on my own and it was
very very tough i mean i literally would
just buy a falafel
gigantic and then split it over three
courses so that one meal could last me
you know i did try to
you know make ends meet and and only
have one meal a day that would last me a
couple so i i did uh maybe
maybe self-enforced because again if i
had called my mom and dad and said look
guys i need you know a thousand dollars
they would have been there for me but
because
peters had barely survived i had taught
myself the wrong lesson instead of being
you know there's three cultures in
building a business there is the
frugality mentality which is the one
that i adopted at peace works where
every dollar is seen as a cost and the
good thing about it is that you make you
stretch every dollar
but the bad thing about is you don't
invest when you should invest in the
opposite corner or the aspect side of
the spectrum of the fugali mentality is
the wasteful mentality which sadly
exists a lot in today where young
entrepreneurs just spend spend spend and
they think that they're going to
eventually have i don't think they call
it the waste approach i think they call
it the growth oriented approach but
continue right
the euphemism employees is the growth
approach that's a great point i'm gonna
uh highlight that that's how they call
it but for me it's wasteful then you're
not respecting money and you're just
spending spending spending and you know
this is why we work hard people paying
thousands of dollars for a desk that
they could have gotten for five hundred
dollars if they had gone down to the
basement as i did my first office
was in the basement of the studio
apartment that i rented and it was 500 a
month but you had to go through the
laundry laundromat and the trash
compactor and it was a windowless
basement and you could smell
the trash compactors odors
losing from under the but that's where i
started not having a lot of meetings in
there
yes i tried not to have any business
meetings there so there's a third
approach between the frugality and where
yes thank you the third approach is the
resourceful mentality
um which i only learned a few years into
kind like initially at time
i saw every
thing as an expense so
anybody that would try a kind bar would
fall in love with it and nine out of 10
people not only would buy again but
would recommend it to friends the data
was insane like but i didn't know better
so i i treated sampling as a cost our
budget for example was 800
[Laughter]
and the 800 was samples to send to the
buyers not to consumers we didn't spend
one dollar getting free products because
we saw that as an expense like if you
want it go and buy it
and when we finally brought in an
investment in 2000 and late 2008 but
basically 2009 is when when we started
we started sampling and that just you
know you you could see the data and then
a few years later our sampling budget
was 20 million dollars
so we went from 800 to 800 thousand
dollars and then the sampling budget
just kept doubling again
and that was far and away the most
important aspect of our marketing i mean
there was nothing else
of significant in our marketing for the
first 10 years other than
giving free kind buys for people to
discover them and then word of mouth to
do its work
[Music]
so i get recognized in public a fair
amount
you know it's like hey are you andrew
yang and it'd be like hey you know
uh where's my thousand dollars that kind
of thing
um
and so when someone finds out that
you're the founder of kind snacks uh do
you feel pressure to be extra nice like
do you have to feel like you have to let
you know like make sure not to be a jerk
to anyone
[Laughter]
i feel that pressure even when they
don't recognize me because by the time
they recognize it's too late right
but i do
i try to do my best to treat people with
dignity and integrity and respect always
i'm a human being i try to remind people
that just because i'm the kind guy i'm
not
perfect and i make mistakes too but i do
think that kind
made me a better human being and it's
very common if you meet kind team
members they will tell you like it was
fascinating because we used to do
surveys and it was fascinating for us to
learn how important kind as a culture
and as a state of mind was to our team
members like they literally felt it made
them
better parents better human beings i do
think that that kind has had a role in
making me a better person
when you're trying to be kind out of
fear of being found to be a fake and to
not be kind is not the best motivator
but when when you see the power of
kindness
when you see that when you like we we
did a lot of social experiments where we
would try to encourage kindness i wrote
a book called do the kind thing a few
years ago
and i walk through all the different
social experiments with it
but one of the things that we discovered
and obviously this is now very well
known is kindness is magical because
it doesn't just make the person that
receives that to kindness
have a lift right and have a better day
it also makes the person doing the kind
act feel better about themselves and
eventually it becomes almost like
something you are addicted to like we
used to do these fun games where we
needed to try to do kind acts to tone
strangers and you realize how
how meaningful it is that when i was in
the subway and i would spot a lady
with her stroller that needed to go off
i was like ding ding ding ding that's
that's a big
there's a kindness opportunity let me
get in there one of my team members like
no but we need to go you have a talk
that you need to be like no this one
this was worth 100 points of like
happiness like i'm going there because
really
you feel good you feel good when you do
something nice for a human being so
that's
what i think my team
talks about when they say that they feel
that
kind mate makes them better people that
we're constantly striving to be
ambassadors of kindness and everybody
makes mistakes but it's an aspiration so
now you are very concerned like i am
about the polarization in the u.s some
of the issues that you saw in the middle
east
are now
very uh relevant here unfortunately and
you've founded a campaign it starts with
us to try and give people
way forward that includes compassion
courage curiosity
uh that we need to empower people
locally to be able to do something
positive where they they live and work
and not wait necessarily for let's say
uh you know political figures to get
their acts together what drove you to
invest in this because you could
obviously you know do anything under the
sun
yeah i've been
noticing
the erosion of american values for me
american values are the ones that i
discovered when i immigrated to america
in 1984
and they include creativity they include
resourcefulness they include respect
respect is in my opinion one of the
greatest things america has that
we take too much for granted but that
doesn't exist in other places like you
have legislators throughout the world
where because that respect doesn't exist
they're dysfunctional you know rule of
law
where
laws are above individuals no human is
above those laws all these things and
you know many others freedom and and
you know freedom of expression and a
real vibrant marketplace of ideas and ah
the curiosity that it takes for us to
look all these things are under threat
today
and i've just been noticing for many
years but just in an accelerated fashion
every every year gets worse
how much these values are under threat
and it does terrify me when i start
noticing
patterns of
talking and behavior about the other
that we have here in america that remind
me of stuff that i've witnessed in the
middle east and in other areas of
conflict
because you know i've been
as the son of a holocaust survivor i've
been my entire life trying to build
bridges and trying to study what does it
take for a society and for human beings
to recognize each other's humanity and
and and learn to respect people that are
different from them
and united states has always been
the place that i draw that inspiration
from and it's terrifying that now
ground zero for
exporting all of these values is now
under threat
and as i started thinking about this
issue you know five or ten years ago but
again in accelerated fashion the last
several years
a few team members and i started doing a
lot of work about it
and ultimately
after you know literally years of going
into you know michigan and pennsylvania
and and interviewing people on the
ground
we realized that
actually values
are shared far more predominantly than
people realize
we think that we are dividing values
that is not true yeah that is absolutely
not true when you talk to
the most conservative person and the
most progressive person and you go deep
to what matters to them as americans
helping those left behind
unites us all we all
americans have this beautiful
temperament helping those left behind
human beings for the most part have but
americans certainly
care about helping those left behind
treating everybody you know with respect
and giving everybody a fair chance and
nobody's above the law and i can give
you a bunch of values that are
fundamental that we all share where we
break down is that
all of us
are not following daily habits
that are required for us to really live
up our best best lives and and
approximate to those values like
it's fascinating we did a survey a
little bit less than a year ago where we
asked how people saw
americans and how they saw themselves
and it's fascinating because
we think everybody's jumanji we're
judging them as judgmental but we think
we are not
same with almost every other data point
like we think we are being when when
when you are not having this
conversation about how people need to be
more respectful and more curious your
audience is gonna nod but they're gonna
not think that they're
in trouble they're gonna think you're
right i observe these in others but we
don't observe it in ourselves
every single one of us is part of the
problem and part of the solution
every single one of us is suffering
from
you know social media
brainwashing us to thinking we're right
because they sell us these algorithms
telling us what we want to hear rather
than what we need to hear and these echo
chambers form where we think we have all
the answers and we are all knowing and
you know all sorts of bs is present
through social media because section 230
has caused one huge sin to humanity
where we don't filter misinformation on
this information the way we used to and
we don't have the training as human
beings together and there's so all these
other reasons but we're becoming very
much more judgmental than we should be
much less forgiving than we should be
much less curious and respectful of
other opinions and this is the
beginnings of what can be very but the
good news is that it's
it is very easy to approach
more compassion
more courage and more
curiosity in our daily lives and
it's a long way to say what starts with
us is giving you tools
through our social media channels and
other things we're creating for how to
live life with with more of those three
c's so let me say that having met tens
of thousands of americans in uh states
and regions around the country i
couldn't agree more that most people
agree in terms of fundamental values
what they want for themselves their
families their communities most people
don't understand is that
you have the people who share a lot of
things
then you have
politicians who have these very
distorted incentives because they need
to placate the 10 percent of
most extreme voters and on both sides
because of the party primary system then
you have a nationalized media network
where they separate us into ideological
camps uh and then you have social media
like you said pouring gasoline on the
whole thing and i think social media
might be the biggest culprit yeah but
those three i agree with you are the the
there's this aggravating divisive
polarizing forces because the political
parties
prey on this sadly because they
themselves are captive
to primary voters that are the most
passionate
but then also the most extreme and so
the entire nation
is basically held hostage to the most
extreme on our on our sides and
these are good people too by the way but
they are
not benefiting from having
flexible minds that respect each other
like i i find it fascinating i keep
meeting incredibly bright people where i
would actually
agree with some of their positions but
they are
so militant in the way they see the
other side they turn me off yeah and
that's what we need to change it's not
that you need to change your values you
need to be less militant about the other
because you're going to lose them when
you're so militant and i'm right and
you're wrong you're going to turn people
off and they're going to move away from
you
[Music]
polarization as you're describing it
worse than ever 42 percent of both
democrats and republicans see the other
side as evil corrupt and a threat to the
country which is this militants you're
talking about so i i've got like a
four-step plan to try and remedy it then
i know you're on board with most of it
is number one try and change the
incentives so that the political parties
aren't quite as beholden to their uh
hyper partisans on each side and part of
that is creating uh
third-party positive unifying centrist
alternatives that
folks have a place to go if they're they
don't feel spoken for by the these two
camps and then some kind of media
alternative so that people who want some
kind of middle ground independent
perspective and then somehow change the
social media mechanics so that you don't
have this uh splintering of the
consciousness and different versions of
truth yeah well i'm very aligned and i'm
doing work on
pretty much
all of the spaces you described
and there are some good fledgling
efforts but let's talk for a second
about the media one
one of the key questions i have is do we
really want it as human beings because
there are a couple nascent efforts that
are trying to provide
more deep more introspective
evaluation of the news of the day we're
we're looking at this and some of them
are encouraging but the problem is
are we as human beings really really
interesting that we as human beings
going to
live because it's so much easier andrew
to be lazy
and to not make americans think harder
it's so much easier for us to not think
harder it requires
emotional strength and mental strength
to just wanna understand the issues
and the media manipulates us and the
politicians manipulate us and social
media this informs us but we are almost
willing sheep oh no we're more subject
to that that's the path of least
resistance i mean that's why the media
companies have figured out he makes more
money exactly it's so much easier to
just be partisan and just be comforted
by hearing what you want to hear rather
than here by using news to affirm your
beliefs rather than to inform your
beliefs and it's super dangerous
but it's it remains to be seen whether
all of us are going to
do a tiny bit of work and i personally
find it much more intellectually
stimulating but it does require a little
more work it's so much easier when
the media just tells you somebody that
you think is a jerk is a jerk like look
how and by the way there are a lot of
jerks there really are a lot of nasty
people i think fundamentally i believe
humans are amazing but men
there really are some absolute jerks out
there
and it's so
you know energizing when somebody says
somebody wants to stick it to the jerk
sure yeah right as the kind guy that i
want to be liked by all sometimes i
don't say you know this person is just
an [ __ ] and then somebody else i said
and i've had this a little bit of like
uh you're like yeah i'm glad that
somebody else said it but ultimately
we're not gonna land in a good place as
a society if we don't find a way to
develop empathy and compassion even for
those we disagree with that's a hard
word
somebody a religious person uh told me
this beautiful thing says that
god equipped us with the ability to be
compassionate for those that it's hard
to be compassionate towards because the
ones that it's easy to be compassionate
for is like of course we're going to be
compassionate we need to develop the
ability to
find a way to
just be patient with those that
we're inclined to initially execute does
not mean that you give up on your values
it means that you're going to be more
effective at advancing those values so
there are definitely some absolute
[ __ ] out there in the world and our
system um is frankly rewarding some
people with very negative tendencies
social media absolutely rewards [ __ ]
like even the opposite right if you're a
thoughtful reflective person
you just don't show up in those stupid
algorithms it's pathetic yeah it's so
you know it's a massive problem i will
say that one experience i have had now
dozens maybe hundreds of times is i've
met someone in person that i had seen
something negative about in the media
and i found them to be perfectly fine uh
positive sometimes even delightful and i
started thinking it's like huh like
maybe i really need to
[Music]
sort of withhold
judgment based upon these media
portrayals um of folks because when i
met them it's like i actually like liked
that person much more more than i
thought so it goes both directions yeah
but it's also
that's a very interesting and complex
problem what i find
is when i meet these politicians in
person
they're much more reasonable and
courteous than when sometimes they take
positions and i think it's a multiple
set of issues part of it is
that humans when they meet they do
develop a little bit more of that
conversation so i think we just need to
meet people that are different from us
because a lot of it will be solved that
way but we're not living places
different from the other and we don't
get to meet people that are different
from us um but also part of the problem
is that we as humans have difficulty
standing up to power and we it's very
hard it's very hard to have the strength
to
even respectfully speak up to somebody
that did something wrong when they are
the leader
and then part of it is that those
leaders when they're with you they're
behaving politely but when they
throw red meat to the most extreme of
their constituencies then they take
positions that are
not principled and i think
we need to work on all of those right
because
those politicians need to develop you
know you also need to develop the
incentive structures that you describe
it's essential to help those politicians
so a lot of them are good people but
they are
just trying to survive in a political
process that has really stupid rules
that that makes it very hard for him to
be
moderate and compassionate and
thoughtful oh yeah our system is just
rewarding
uh negative behaviors and more
ideological stances uh and so then
expecting them to go against that grain
is tough you also have a tip something
under that you have achieved something
that is very interesting and special but
when you're able to say what needs to be
said and most times
have people
give you the benefit of that because
they know
that you mean well they know that you're
authentic
and they know that you are trying to
make this a better world people get that
about you and i think that's a very cool
thing you've achieved uh i saw
a post that you wrote
about
how media should not be on twitter
and the commentary was quite you had a
lot of thousands tens of thousands of
likes but the comments were some of them
were very nasty what i asked myself is
is it that the people that take the time
to comment are the most extreme
or
is it that you
touch the raw nerve on that particular
issue and how do you deal with that
because i can't do that i
i may be as the son of a holocaust
survivor or maybe i'm just immature
i have not developed the strength to
just
always speak my mind
even when i'm gonna piss off you know 50
of population i don't think i could be a
politician because automatically
half the population from the other
parties are going to hate you
how do you deal with
with those issues well it helps that
i've been through versions of it before
daniel
it was like the first time i was like
whoa i'm getting a lot of uh hate and
like that the first time i got a lot of
hate
um
it was during the presidential campaign
and i'd spoken to a group of
asian americans who are you know frankly
that they were less politically engaged
than other groups and and were the most
underrepresented uh in part for that
reason so i said to them hey we're a
generation away from asians getting shot
by americans on the basis of their race
because uh like hostility between the us
and china said this in 2018. some people
then
took those comments and put them out
online and then people attacked me as
being very uh reactionary and
unreasonable
and it really knocked me for a loop for
a minute i was like oh you know like
people are really mad at me about this
you know i grappled with it's like well
did i actually mean what i said it's
like yeah i genuinely thought that was
going to happen and i was like speaking
to a very specific community and trying
to activate them in a particular way so
i've now had that experience or versions
of it like dozens of times
that's the story as someone who's on
social media a fair amount as part of my
job in you know it's like i see how it
screws you up um like i like to think
that it hasn't screwed me up quite as
badly as it's you know screwed some
other people up but
it's certainly a very powerful
uh influence but also by the way
social media
commentaries accentuate the negatives
because
most people probably would not
if you had a hundred people in
real life listening to you share that
very thoughtful commentary which was
provocative but it was interesting
probably 99 would be
respectful and not
maybe a hundred would not be incendiary
but
the
anonymity and impersonality of these
platforms makes people just
say things
in ways that are so much more negative
and also probably inspires people that
are much more comfortable
with that
being the most active so i think it
there's just a whole set of dynamics
you don't think there's personality
traits or formative influences in your
life that made you better equipped for
what you're doing than others
like for example i i give myself
i've analyzed myself a lot in this front
but i think that
i think that
one of the things that shaped me the
most was being the son of a holocaust
survivor like that learning starting at
the age of nine what my father went
through in a concentration camp and also
how he was liberated by american
soldiers through a lot of lessons i mean
you know on one side build bridges at
all costs and try to build bridges on
the other side have the courage to stand
up to evil no matter what even if you
need to fight because i to be clear if i
need to fight for america if i need to
fight for my children i will fight to
the death i mean i i will not walk away
because that was one of the most
important lessons that my dad uh
instilled upon me but on the other side
i also want to be building bridges so i
don't know that for me that is the path
for you what were the formative
influences that made you
be strong and able to do what you do
today you know i'm about to give a
commencement speech at a high school
next week so i've been reflecting on
this a little bit uh because i wanted to
impart lessons to them that actually
were relevant to a high school kid
so i was the son of immigrants
in upstate new york one of the only
asian kids and i was deeply
self-conscious very introverted i got
teased and
marginalized pretty regularly i'd also
skipped a grade so i was smaller and
scrawnier than everyone else so i was
always the odd man out and it pained me
deeply
um and so my reaction to that when i
grew older was to go to the gym a lot
and get mad and drink protein shakes
that's one reason why i'm a kind bar
way of like this arc i was gonna say you
played basketball with my kids once and
they thought you were really good so
so that was part of it too like where
it's like well as an asian kid i started
to like basketball and then i'd be like
it would be humiliating
if i was a big nba fan watching it but i
couldn't play a lake so i was like well
i better [ __ ] learn how to play but i
think one reason why i'm able to do this
daniel is that i was embarrassed and
humiliated so much as a kid that like
you know eventually now i'm like kind of
immune to various aspects of it i also
went to
a prep school in new hampshire and then
law school
and i was around people who were
political uh you and i met
president obama multiple times but you
and i have met dozens hundreds of
political figures and in 2016 after
trump won
i thought well i should do something to
help so then you say okay like let me
put myself out there um and and now
uh i do have a following and i see
myself as one of like a relatively small
number of people who might be able to
avert the catastrophes that you and i
see ahead um so now it becomes a very
straightforward thing where it's like of
course i'm gonna do it because i'm an
american i'm a parent like i'm like you
uh you know i'll fight like mad for
this country
let me ask you a related question
you said that you now see yourself as
one of a few people that can help avert
this
and
you earlier you talked about how
i get things done right like i call it
being an actionist rather than seeing
the glass half full or half empty stop
talking maybe
just get it done just do something about
it i definitely have inside me i don't
know if it came from my parents or where
it came from i believe that i can change
the world for the better i definitely
have not just that but also i believe
that i have to
play a role in you know i can't just
leave the world the way i found it
because it's too dangerous because then
we'll see the the space toast
and but i believe that that is for all
human beings that's when i started one
voice when it started starts with us
it's about giving humans agency over
their power
and with that power
the responsibility that comes with that
power
to be protagonists in our lives and to
take our lives back and to make this a
better world not to wait for others to
do it because it's not gonna happen
you know what i have observed is that if
you're waiting around for other
politicians or other people to get
critical stuff done it doesn't happen if
you believe in it and you start doing it
then people will join you and do it but
i really firmly believe
that all of us have a role to plan a
duty to play it
and yet it is true that you and i
see that almost you know embarrassingly
messianic belief that we have
the
ability to do something so where did
that come from you did it really only
come you know after you run for
president or did you see that before and
why why what do you think it happens and
do you think all human beings
have that power and need to find it or
honestly just to be frank
uh not everybody sees their power to
change the world
uh i think that everyone has
incredible capacities that are going
under utilized or unutilized 99 of the
time because the world doesn't ask that
of them i think it's one reason why i
love entrepreneurs so much is that like
you know entrepreneurs aren't activating
100 of our potential but we're
activating a much higher proportion of
it than the average person who's being
asked to do very very little for me
my confidence was inspired in part by my
parents
where my parents drilled into me when i
was young if you don't do it it's
because you didn't try hard enough it's
not because you didn't have the ability
i took that to heart
and so i thought well if someone else
can do something i can do it too and
that really was informed by my time at
this prep school philip sexter academy
which was
regarded as one of the best high schools
in the country um and so i was around a
lot of old money patrician
uh new englanders uh who you know were
from very very successful families and
the rest of it and going to school with
those kids i did not come away thinking
that they were any better than me
i was like you know it's like i'm you
know i'm just as good as any of them and
so i like i i had this sense it's like
okay like i should be able to do things
if other people can do them no i wish
more people felt like they had greater
possibilities um i i don't want to
mislead anyone in the sense that uh like
you said uh you know if things ever got
really
terrible for me i i had like you know uh
home and a family i could go back to and
be like hey you know i need a meal you
know
like that i mean there are realities uh
that are out there but right now
most people are
not asked to come anywhere near their
potential and if we could activate more
people's potential then that's the path
out of this but something you said that
uh that spoke to me a lot that i think
is really important for all of us to
reflect on is you also said
a lot of us don't know that we have it
till we're called upon to exercise that
leadership and i do think it's it's very
powerful you know there's that person
that is walking on the street and all of
a sudden is called upon to be a hero to
help somebody that got hurt or to stop
somebody that's bad or something and we
never realized that we have that courage
inside us till we're called upon to
exercise it and i think it's the time
has come
the time has come for all americans
all of us to unite and do we're not
expecting you to
you know stop feeding your children and
sacrifice
we're but we all of us need to join
forces and saying enough is enough with
this polarization and this is my way to
contribute i'm going to try to practice
these habits of compassion towards those
that are different from me courage to
try to listen together and collaborate
with those across lines of difference
and first and foremost curiosity for me
to grow and have the strength to try to
learn we just start in our daily lives
working a little bit at a time with that
we literally we literally will move
steer the ship back on course because
just like it's been of course the last
several years because we're not
exercising these daily habits
we can ourselves it's really literally a
part of us it starts with us to do that
and a lot of the work you're doing is
going to require people to step up and
join and just do a little modicum or
something to build
that movement of respect that we need to
be a part of well i love this because
it's something that everyone can take on
it's something everyone can do
you know we can't control necessarily
the actions of
the these people on social media or
political leaders but we can control our
own uh attitudes and habits and our
approach to people
if this country does make it through
this time daniel i have a feeling that
you're gonna be a big reason why uh you
you are a natural
leader unifier uh and i know after this
they're going to be a lot of people that
want to help and support you in anything
that you do so if someone does want to
help spread this word uh and join you
how can they they best do so well i hope
that uh and by the way i wasn't trying
to advertise that they need to join
starts with us or daniel lubetsky or
andrew young you need to find what it is
for them but since you're giving me the
opportunity i do want to encourage
everybody to start by just following me
on my
social media handles at daniel lubetsky
and following starts with us starts with
dot u s
but find whatever gives you meaning as
you start listening to andrew's uh
work and to the stuff we share on our
channels and others find what gives you
that energy and what gives you the
meaning but find something but every one
of us needs to be part of this because
those that don't
approach life with those three c's
are not stopping and they will never
stop because they have you know the
difference and i shared this a long time
ago people laugh about it but it really
is true the overwhelming majority of
people are thoughtful moderates and it's
only a small percentage of people that
are just extremists let alone violent
extremists but the thing about
extremists is that they wake up in the
morning and they're like how am i going
to advance my costs how am i going to
dance they're very passionate they
advance their cause
moderates wake up in the morning they're
like
what am i going to have for breakfast
what am i going to eat for breakfast and
that's the disconnect right the
moderates
they don't realize their agency they
don't realize their power responsibility
to
advance respect and moderations and
centrism and so extremists tend to hold
those hostage on guns on almost every
political issue i've been doing work
recently the last year almost every
political issue
i believe we could get 70 or 80 percent
of the population to agree on common
sense legislation not on everything
we're gonna agree on everything there's
gonna be disagreements but you can
advance
you can make so much progress but we're
held hostage by the extremes and we're
making no progress we're completely
paralyzed and stagnant and so we really
need to rise up and and
and demand and make our voices be more
heard and speak to our congress people
and be more present and say look you
know
let's come up with comments and
solutions to all of these problems that
are ailing us all extreme moderates
unite indeed
i couldn't agree with you more if you
had a rational political system we could
come together on a lot of things and
also agree that if people are courageous
compassionate and curious it's going to
be a better country thank you so much
daniel you're an awesome friend and
champion for humanity uh and you know
you're helping keeping some of us like a
little bit healthier and maybe even a
little bit more kind every single day i
appreciate the heck out of you man
thank you andrew and thanks to all of
your listeners
you